ah can you totally chillax i'm
so annoyed right now can you like not
talk to me for like a second
like that'd be great that'd be fine
that'd be fine by me
but oh my god are you serious this is
bull
what could possibly be the problem with
letting two more people in
check your girl bro excuse me what did
you say
check your girl uh-uh it doesn't work
like that no one checks me
because i'm not luggage okay so you can
go
yourself megan seriously
two more people are gonna come out in a
couple of seconds and then we can go
in now let me ask you a question what
was it like being in the green mile
he wasn't in the green mile he clearly
wasn't in that movie
what does tom hanks's penis feel like
megan moreover how does it feel when
swarms of bees are coming out of your
face
seriously i'm sorry sucker favorite
movie don't apologize for me
yeah this is nice this is nice you look
like common meets the incredible hulk
when you brought the frankincense to
baby jesus did they like
make you stand outside the barn because
you were too big or did they invite you
in with all the other animals
don't flare your nostrils at me do you
have any idea how impolite that is
he hasn't moved his nostrils once
since we got here i saw the move they
did not move me again they
flare megan they did not move your
nostrils flared more than a survivor
from a boat accident
what he's not even looking in the eyes
okay you know what if you're just gonna
continue to be a little prick you're
gonna get your
ass kicked don't touch your m meegan
crazy [ __ ]
oh i totally love my nails right now
so over everything right now over the
floor i'm over the sky i'm over you
over that [ __ ] back there you're a
[ __ ]
megan seriously whatever
um excuse me
oh god hey what did you say what the
[ __ ] did you just say you guys come back
here with your little
itty-bitty dicks
you best control your lady yep oh
control your lady no he doesn't control
me cause let me tell you something
i'm not a remote megan baby can we just
let this go
no i'm talking to the [ __ ] of anarchy
right now yeah you
why don't you all gather yourselves and
why don't you just go
and figure out a way to on each other's
leathery penis
hey you [ __ ]
it's not even the plural of penis
yeah i'm not queen of the
world yes i feel invincible
like i have superpowers or something
you hear that all you ask the world i
can do anything i want
and no one can stop me guess you don't
have to fight your own fights a crazy
[ __ ]
oh boy oh
nothing can stop me
you